the Joe Rogan experience so I take the
worst most embarrassing stuff that
happens and talk about it because that
is gives you a front-row seat at what
training the mine actually looks like
and if you can't have a sense of humor
about how crazy you are
you are truly [ __ ] I think that those
uncomfortable moments are so important
for other people to hear about yeah yes
absolutely we need to know we're not
alone yes when all our madness what was
it like on the set when you were working
with Dave Chappelle it was great well
I've known Dane for a long time I was
actually on the very first episode we by
chance I was walking through New York
and I saw Dave and this is before the
show had even been even know it existed
but I ran into Bobcat Goldthwait who's
there and Mike what's up man what are
you guys doing he's like he was oh hey
Joe we're doing a TV schedule want to be
in on it and I go I only have like 20
minutes
oh wait a minute was here he goes we're
handing out ribbons for New York boobs
and he had a box so it's me and him
walking through Manhattan and he's got
this crazy fake mustache on he's like
you've got the best New York boobs and
he would give someone like a ribbon for
heaven New York believes him it was
really silly but fun and so I was like
wow Dave's got a show and then you know
turns out it's the greatest sketch show
in the history of the world and a year
later he calls me up again and asked me
to do this thing for they wanted to do a
fear factor sketch with Tyrone Biggums
yeah so that's me and him a fresh-faced
Joe Rogan and Dave Chappelle oh thank
you yeah well this is like what yours is
that's two thousand three four yeah I
think it's before that is it I think
it's before that I want to say it's to
2002 maybe yeah
because I wasn't even doing the man show
back then and I was doing that in 2003
so I think it's 2002 the fear factor bit
is one of my favorite that's a season
two if I recall I think so yeah and is
really one of the sliminess
one of the funniest bits in a show that
is I would argue perhaps the greatest
television show of all time I think it's
the greatest sketch comedy show of all
time
yeah I'm saying something bigger it's
hard to say that though because if you
boiled down
lot of the all-time great shows like in
living color some of the other ones but
they had so many seasons if you boiled
them down to two seasons maybe there
would be some but he's got some sketches
that worse just groundbreaking like the
black white supremacist who was blind
what about I was watching last night
because Jeff and I were talking about
last night so I won the car ride home
from this event we did together
I was watching black bush which was
another I think unbelievable which was
up season 2 where he plays george w bush
his version of your journey and all the
rationales for going into the war in
iraq and it's unbelievably funny yeah
he's a genius he's a real comedy genius
but also a guy who's you know you
wouldn't get it if you just sort of see
him do stand up but he's deeply
introspective yeah very intensely well
thought out you know he's not he's not a
surface guy by any stretch of the
imagination I love him I really do yeah
well I love thinking that shows gonna
come back at some point
his Netflix specials are better I just
like seeing him unfucked with in unless
Netflix let him do a Chappelle show
where they just left him alone
then he genius but we think that was the
problem in season percent yeah I know it
was he was they were telling him what to
say they were telling him there is so
much money involved that they were
trying to get him to slightly
watered-down his content in order to
make it more palatable for advertisers
they were asking him does not say the
n-word there was a lot of behind the
scenes nonsense that I dealt with the
exact same administration and Comedy
Central so I'm well aware of how silly
they were about certain things they had
these corporate ideas and this was also
right around the same time Janet
Jackson's nipple popped out there in the
Superbowl which [ __ ] oddly enough
changed everything people started
freaking out about content because of a
nipple it was it was very it was a very
weird time for television and in their
defense what they do is their producers
they're not they're not creative people
they're executives and they
didn't know how to handle how to keep it
funny and keep it free and loose but
also figure out a way to make it fit
into what their corporate structure is
of what's acceptable and not acceptable
for advertising so it was just a
[ __ ] of control and neediness and
too many cooks in the kitchen and and
people's ego but there's a lot of people
that just wanted to affect the show just
so that they could put their greasy
fingerprints on it and that's a really
common thing with television that that
ego aspect of you know these different
people who are high up on the food chain
in the you know executive world wanting
to put their stamp on a show and then
talking openly about putting their stamp
well that was my idea I thought I was
really important we get Dave out there
like that
and it for him he was like [ __ ] this I'm
going to Africa for a couple months and
I'm just gonna come back and quit and
everybody was like whoa but that's who
Dave is I mean that's that's there's not
a lot of people that walk away from 50
million dollars but he's one of them
he's just like no I don't need to do
this I could I could do something else I
just just stand up and he in fact we
even weirder he didn't do stand-up for a
long time and when he did it he did it
for free he would just show up places
like he would show up places with a
speaker I'm plugging into a microphone
in a park in Seattle and just start
doing stand-up there was a lot of
stories of that people just gather out
hundreds of people and he would just be
doing stand-up for these random people
and they were like what's going on how
does a guy get to be like that just be
yourself
that's who he is what was that do you
think is that something because that
sounds to me like somebody who had a
practice or something or like or an
inner compass that was mocked a lot of
weed that maybe that was it he smokes
weed all day I mean if you watch this
new Netflix special he's smoking a vape
pen through the entire special to the
point where I watched it and like 40
minutes in this brush I started getting
anxiety of like how high are you right
now man you said you might wait were you
hiding your Netflix but yes okay yeah
yeah because you said at the beginning
you were baked and I was like that a bit
or is he you know I was high but I
didn't keep getting high through the
special like Dave keeps hitting that
vape pen and I don't know how strong
that vape pen is but he's like seven
eight
nine ten hits deep in 40 minutes in I'm
like yo this could get super slippery
yeah he just kept pulling out this vape
pen yeah I mean it was literally with
him through the entire set in his hand
that's increasing the degree of
difficulty that I would not want to
express what an isolation tank
[Applause]